كل شيء روتيني تمامًا حتى لا
تكون قوة مشاة البحرية الأمريكية
جاهزة
بينما يتصارع قادة العالم مع
السؤال المتشابك ، ماذا تفعل بشأن إيران
في قلب الأحداث ، ملاكم يو إس إس في
طريقه إلى المضايق المتوترة بالفعل
من المشكلين.  لنا أن
هذا يمكن أن يجعل الوضع
الوضع الجيوسياسي أكثر استقرارًا
هناك المروحية الصغيرة التي تلاحقها
نوعًا ما  يُلقى باللوم على إيران في
هجمات مزعومة على ست ناقلات نفط
في هذه المنطقة هذا العام ، وتنفي إيران
مسؤوليتها لكنها غاضبة من انسحاب الولايات المتحدة
من اتفاق لرفع
العقوبات مقابل تعليق
الضربات الجوية التي تم سحبها ردًا
على مضيق هامر يو إس إس.
الملاكم هو من الناحية الفنية
سفينة هجومية برمائية ، ما يعنيه ذلك حقًا هو
أنها حاملة طائرات
مليئة بمشاة البحرية الأمريكية ، وهي وسيلة
يمكن للولايات المتحدة من خلالها أن تعرض
قوة حقيقية حقيقية للعضلات ترسل إشارة لا لبس فيها
في هذه المنطقة في الوقت الحالي
وعبور روتيني لحماية الشحن.
الممرات التي تمر عبر المضيق والتي تجلب
سفينة بهذا الحجم تحمل 1500 من مشاة البحرية
داخل موقع الساحل الإيراني
ستُنظر إليها حتماً على أنها استفزازية في
طهران خطأ صغير لأن
خيوط الملاكم عبر المضيق يمكن أن تتسبب في
كارثة
عندما تجري هذه الأنواع من العمليات.
هناك احتمال
لتأثير استراتيجي من خطأ
صغير دقيق تمامًا
وكل التدريب  نحن نقوم بكل التعليم
الذي نقوم به هو
الهدف الصريح الذي نحصل عليه بعد أن
يقول قادة إيران إنهم يريدون الحفاظ على
الاتفاق النووي حياً ، والولايات المتحدة لإنهاء
العقوبات التجارية التي تشل
اقتصادها ، يرون أن الوجود الأمريكي هنا
يمكن أن يكون متفجرًا للولايات المتحدة.
تتدخل الدول من أجل جعل هذه
المياه غير آمنة بالنسبة لإيران ، لا يمكنك جعل
هذه المياه غير آمنة لدولة ما
وآمنة للآخرين ، ولا يمكنك ببساطة
تجاهل احتمال وقوع كارثة
ولكننا جميعًا بحاجة إلى العمل من أجل
تجنب واحدة مر بها أسطول السفن.
المضائق دون عوائق سربها الجوي
يراقب رأسه
كلقب يكشف بالصدفة كيف
إيران والولايات المتحدة  يرى كل منهما الآخر
عيون شريرة سام كيلي سي إن إن على الملاكم يو إس إس